elle adore s'amuser elle adore s'occuper
des animaux et donc son mari le roi
louis saez en personne a décidé de lui
offrir ici à rambouillet dans son
domaine une magnifique laiterie petit
d'explications historiques pour ses
enfants de 7 à 12 ans avant de se lancer
dans l'aventuré
pendant ses vacances la laiterie de la
reine d'acheter par louis saez en 1783
devient un espace de jeux pour les plus
jeunes leur défi apprendre à travers les
cinq sens pourquoi avoir choisi les sens
parce que ici quand marie antoinette
elles venaient
on peut dire vraiment que tous ses sens
étaient en alerte on avait ces animaux
qui étaient là les odeurs des produits
laitiers etc des choses qu'aujourd'hui
on a complètement disparu parce qu on
est vraiment dans un moment à part
entière qui a perdu finalement son âme
identifié un médaillon simplement le
touchant ou encore reconnaître un
produit laitier au bout des épreuves
parfois un peu compliqué comme ce
parcours à l'aveuglé
jamais les yeux bandés et j'ai dû j'ai
dû écouter quelqu'un pour me guider dans
un dans un circuit et il y avait
quelqu'un d'autre qui me disent l
inverse
c'est bien c'est marrant et puis j'aime
bien
après tous ces efforts un peu de repos
bien mérité dans la salle fraîcheur de
marie-antoinette la laiterie de la reine
a que les enfants de 3 à 12 ans les
mercredis jeudis vendredis et samedis
jusqu'au 7 mars prochain